the London system now has a 100 win rate
in the world championship surely he's
not going for the London system or any
other things associated to Knight F3 yes
he does yes oh no oh no oh no the London
dingley Wren became the first player to
ever play the London in a world
championship and what a game it was
after nepo tried to break free of ding's
positional squeeze the position exploded
in tactics Knight D6 earned a brilliant
move and a winning Advantage but it was
the spectacular conclusion that stunned
the Chess World the devilish D5 pours
off from a distance a mating net which
baffled other super GMS fish queen of
seven
I'm gonna take this and Checkmate you oh
the amazing Queen F7 setting up an
Unstoppable Queen sacrifice with Queen
takes G8 how do you even spawn this it's
completely Beyond me how you can proceed
from from afar you must be told genius
with no defense Nepal resigned so